I'd get ready for Fast Times the
Lamborghini Las Vegas Polo classic is
back in the South Point Arena next month
that's right well this year you can also
explore the Blue Heron homes up in
Henderson with the polo players these
are Majestic places and in fact that's
where we find Candace Charles this
morning with how you can join us good
morning Candace
you are right Heather I am standing in
front of a Lamborghini right now good
morning
folks and I'm joined by the one and only
Polo Americas Randy Russell thank you so
much for joining us tell us a little bit
about the Classic this is not the first
time you guys have been in Vegas no this
will be our fifth event out here it's a
Lamborghini Las Vegas Polo classic it's
going to be May 12th and 13th it's going
to be incredible we have a beautiful
home up here at 681 Dragon Peak yeah
it's 14.5 million right that's correct
amazing amazing The Blue Heron building
Douglas element made an arrangements for
our meet and greet with the polo players
on Friday night so we'll have a big
cocktail party here on Saturday night at
South Point we've got uh Polo golf cart
Polo Lamborghini runway show it's 200 a
ticket all-inclusive and it sounds like
it's going to be a good time Randy folks
will get to try out this of course
Mikimoto jewelry and as well as get to
try out the Lambos of course and I have
been software here from Lamborghini Las
Vegas tell us really how fast these
babies go I know that folks will be able
to kind of feel them around them right
absolutely well this is the 2020
Lamborghini Urus performante it does
0-60 in 3.0 seconds 657 horsepower the
thing is quite the incredible machine
yeah it sounds like it you guys get to
enjoy all of this on May 12th and the
13th 200 for a ticket all details on the
website newsnow.com I'm going to try
this baby out with you Ben you're ready
to go all right for now live from
McDonald's I'm Candace Charles a news
now